15 years I mean I feel like that's a
long time for a sequel uh but I know
everyone's so excited was it surreal
sort of stepping back on set and sort of
seeing all these characters come to life
again
yeah because it had been a long time and
it had been all we're gonna do it this
year and it kept getting pushed to the
next year and then it finally happened
so I didn't quite believe it until I
actually landed in Ireland and started
rehearsing
and um it was still really strange
because everything was remote
because of covet in the lockdown and
shooting during lockdown is very
challenging to say the least doing
anything during lockdown is challenging
but
um
but what was really fun is when we got
into the rehearsal process with the
singing and the dancing and the
choreography that's when it kind of it
came together and it became really fun
and it felt like
a summer camp mixed in with getting
ready for a Broadway show so that was
cool I I really enjoyed that actually a
lot
well that was that leads into my next
question perfectly I mean you do sing in
this film I mean were you nervous
excited how did you sort of approach it
I was really excited and completely
nervous and um you know I was really
very well supported with the singing
coach and you know get a chance to get
into the dancing and all the dancers and
everyone and the musicians were very
kind to me and very supportive and I
really enjoyed the process a lot it was
a lot of fun and then when you're
singing the vibration of what it does
it's very intoxicating and you get high
from it you know I think it's the
vibration and the breathing and all of
that and uh
you know you think about
the history of all of the musicals and
and all of that and being a part of that
Disney tradition was uh it was really
fun and nerve-wracking
I imagine and obviously you have like
Amy and Idina who are obviously so well
versed in singing already did you get
any tips from them or did you kind of
want to approach games as well James is
a really good singer he he's got a great
voice uh really funny so yeah they were
all you know because we were all kind of
in our little pods we didn't get a
chance to get together that much because
you know we were concerned about
shutting down production and covet so we
didn't get a chance to really see each
other until we started performing
together and shooting so it was like a
lot going on in one time
you know this film is very much about
you know maybe the happy happily ever
after you wanted or isn't exactly what
you got but what is you know if you
could think of your happily ever after
what would it be for you
I think just being grateful for what you
have and you know whatever comes on top
of that even more so but I think that's
the key to the happiness is just accept
what's in front of you enjoy that if you
can improve it great if not then accept
it and make the most of it
and then uh lastly uh you know like I
said 15 years since the first one I know
fans are so excited you know is there
anything you can tease for fans any sort
of things that maybe you did
specifically for fans or sort of like
kind of fan service stuff
yeah it's fun because everybody gets to
uh
it's fun certainly for me because I get
to turn everything upside down
um and get to play in a different way so
that's I I will be interesting to see
what people think of that